welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
morning there's been rumors released
that the next ant-man storyline will
appear on Disney Plus rather than be a
fully fledged film for the franchise
this comes from infamous Lord of the
leaks himself Mikey Sutton who famously
broke news about spider-man being in
civil war back when Disney was denying
it and the MCU head has built a big
reputation recently for coming out with
news way before it makes it to the
headlines today Mikey posted the
following discussing ant-man's return
when ant-man was released in 2015 Marvel
Studios didn't have access to the x-men
and Fantastic Voyage it was easier and
perhaps necessary for them to take
chances on lesser known characters that
they own the rights to but with the
mutants and the FF now in the Disney
catalogue awaiting theatrical space
after billions spent on Fox it will
become tougher for even the smallest of
Heroes to find a spot on the roster I
found out before D 23 that the sequel to
ant-man in the wasp wasn't going to be
announced their first I love the ant-man
movies they're among my favorites in the
MCU witty quirky and fun they capture
childhood memories of reading Bronze Age
Marvel Comics modestly budgeted both
below 200 million the ant-man movies
were certainly hits especially overseas
they grossed 500 to 600 million range
worldwide which was what they were
expecting however when you have heavy
hitters like the x-men and the Fantastic
Four on the bench and you can only
produce a certain amount of movies every
year you have to prioritize I was told
weeks ago that Disney is weighing the
options for the ant-man franchise and
that leads to Disney Plus it may seem
like a step down but it isn't the Disney
Plus Marvel shows are Feige productions
with large budgets as of this moment
ant-man is headed to Disney Plus in the
form of a miniseries this could change
however as Marvel wants to pursue new
genres with shang-chi and blade while
tapping into the Fox IPs in the future
the ant-man franchise is literally made
for Disney plus they were highly popular
with families
the cord is d+ demography
they weren't made to be billion-dollar
blockbusters and this will enable them
to flesh out the supporting cast of
characters such as Louise every day is
like Sunday
Mikey sir now whether this turns out to
be true or not and I have to reiterate
that this is a rumor it does make a lot
of sense ant-man when you look at the
grosses always makes a profit but in
terms of other films I think it's safe
to say that the movies box office is
rather modest as certain says the
character is built for families and
Scott Hope and Cassie certainly feel a
better fit to me at least to be in a TV
show rather than a full film this could
also explain why we never got an
announcement of a third film in the face
for lineup as ant-man films to this
point have been rather small-scale
excuse the pun and there's no reason why
he can't adapt to smaller screens excuse
the pun again we know that Disney Plus
has been put in place for characters
like this so it makes a lot of sense to
really use the platform to tell these
kind of stories and I think even if the
rumor is unverified it does sound like
it has the potential to be true reading
the headline and report this just makes
sense and seems to be a smart move on
Disney's part who now have attained so
many franchises that it makes sense just
to ship things out I think it's a big
win for Disney plus two and almost makes
the platform required at this point
because of all the big shows that it has
on it Paul Rudd is of course really busy
too with the upcoming Ghostbusters
reboot and the new Netflix show that
he's doing which could branch off into a
second season if it's successful so this
makes sense in terms of his calendar as
well
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this and if you think it's
fair on the character or not comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and share
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of all the times that penny
wise appeared in the background of a
scene and it chapter one in two I
guarantee there's some in there that you
missed so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey also just want to let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the m-mine news in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on October the 15th and the blue
arrow be shipped out from then - if it
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]